bueno creo que ha sido muy interesante
oír este discurso de guillermo lasso al
final ha sido un discurso que uno podría
calificarlo de muy genérico no ha dicho
cosas que en realidad supongo que para
la mayoría de oyentes de francia 20
france24 deben ser obviedades no ha
hablado de la importancia de la
democracia la división de poderes la
libertad el respeto a la ley la igualdad
de género en realidad ha hablado de
cosas que para cualquier habitante de un
país democrático son obviedades y yo
creo que eso es lo más interesante de la
del discurso de lazo es que en estas
obviedades está habiendo una ruptura con
el pasado es decir el ecuador no vivió
nada de eso en los últimos años no
tuvimos una división de poderes no
tuvimos una libertad no tuvimos el
respeto a la ley no se fomentó la
igualdad de género es interesante ver
como la propuesta de lazo no es más que
convertir al ecuador en un país normal y
yo creo que ese va a ser uno de los
mayores retos que va a tener guillermo
lasso en llevar al ecuador a ser un país
normal en el cual
respete la ley en el cual el gobierno se
limite en función de la ley en el cual
haya pesos y contrapesos cosas que
insisto muchos de los oyentes de estas
de este de este noticiero estoy seguro
que las entienden como obvias pero no el
ecuador no vivió eso en los últimos 14
años sobre todo en el periodo que va de
2007 a 2017 ecuador no vivió eso y el
mayor reto será volver hacia allá con
una crisis económica encima no nos
olvidemos ecuador lleva ya
[Música]
ocho trimestres consecutivos de
contracción de la economía eso eso no lo
hemos vivido nunca en la historia
ecuatoriana y convertir al ecuador en un
país democrático todo sobre la ley con
un gobierno que se ciña a lo que la ley
le dice va a ser complejo para guillermo
lasso como se vaticina entonces la
relación de guillermo lasso con
entidades como el fondo monetario
internacional por ejemplo con la que
ecuador tiene un acuerdo
y yo estoy seguro que va a ser una buena
relación en el sentido de que lazó
entiende que ciertas reformas son
absolutamente inevitables pero al mismo
tiempo va a ser una relación en la cual
el ecuador va a exigir mucho de esas
instituciones de gor va a exigir mucho
del banco mundial del fondo monetario
porque ecuador tiene conciencia de que
el camino a seguir se es básicamente el
mismo que van a proponer esas
instituciones pero yo creo que el
gobierno del lazo tiene también una
conciencia de que la velocidad de avance
en la que se debe ir hacia esas metas de
equilibrar el gasto público este tipo de
cosas tiene que estar en función de las
sensibilidades sociales es decir tenemos
estamos en una región en la cual muchos
países han tenido problemas por querer
hacer ajustes muy rápido pues tenemos
que aprender de eso tenemos sacar una
lección si usted quiere tenemos sacar
una lección de la historia colombiana de
las últimas semanas porque el programa
de ajuste que estoy seguro que el
gobierno de laso está convencido que
debe implementarse debe hacerlo de una
gradual cuidadosa sin herir sin
despertar en problemas sociales